So far I've used the term pixel.
Let's try to understand what that pixel is in the context of an image.
A pixel, or a picture element, is basically the element that
contains the light intensity at some location within that image.
In this case i and j of that image.
So for example, what we're really interested in is now we have the scope and
the boundary of this image here, which is known by its width and height.
But I also want to know within it at any location here what would
be various intensities within that image?
And I want to be able to do this for all aspects or all parts of this image.
So for example at the ith and the jth index, this is the val, this is the pixel.
What would be the intensity value at that location?
In essence, a computational aspect of all of this is,
that I want to be able to create either a discrete representation or
a continuous representation that I can now, by giving it values of i and j,
give it some numeric value of what this image would be.
Because once I get this numerical value, I could use it for
various types of computational steps.